your paranasal sinuses
are air filled spaces in the bones
around your nose
they are connected to the inside of your
nose through small passageways
a thin layer of tissue called nasal
mucosa
lines the inside of your nose and your
sinuses
this tissue makes a thick and slippery
fluid
called mucus mucus keeps your nose from
drying out
moistens the air you breathe and
protects against
germs dust and pollen when your sinuses
are healthy
mucus can drain freely out of your nose
sometimes your mucosa may become swollen
and inflamed causing your sinuses to be
blocked
the blockage can trap mucus inside your
sinuses
if this condition lasts more than three
months it's called
chronic sinusitis
if medication or other treatments aren't
helping your health care provider may
advise you to have surgery
endoscopic sinus surgery is the most
common procedure for chronic sinusitis
to start the surgeon will insert a
camera on the end of a thin
tool called an endoscope into your nose
images from the camera will be sent to a
video screen so that your surgeon can
see the inside of your nose
then your surgeon will look for and
remove anything that blocks the opening
to your sinuses
this will allow mucus to drain from your
sinuses and
improve airflow after the procedure you
may have nasal bandages
for a few days your healthcare provider
will ask you to use a saline
rinse to help you recover
talk to your healthcare provider to find
out more about endoscopic sinus surgery